- So, what do Jews believe
happens when you die?
- Um,
I think it's like,
we believe in heaven,
but we don't necessarily believe in hell.
So, I guess it's like
everyone goes to heaven.
That doesn't make sense.
- You ordered a sandwich?
On Passover?
- Oh, oops. (chuckles)
- You're not having any lox on your bagel.
- I don't really like lox.
- I've never heard of that.
- I guess it's like...
you live on through your grandkids,
or maybe just your kids.
- You know you're supposed
to use the shamash, right?
- Is that a ham sandwich?
- Yeah, it's ham and cheese.
- Ham and cheese?
- Come on, have a taste.
- Is that the kippot from my bar mitzvah?
- So, you're Jewish, but you don't,
you're not a practicing Jew?
- Ah, that's so sweet.
What is this?
- It's Manischewitz!
- A couple months ago, when
I was home for Christmas--
- Christmas?
(reciting blessings)
- [Voiceover] Do you have a bar mitzvah?
- No, I chose not to do that.
- You chose not to have a...
huge party with all your friends there?
DJ, catered food?
- And what are you giving Bernie?
- Give him like 20 bucks.
- You don't know about 18, 36?
- You should be going to Greenblatt's.
- Greenblatt's?
- Yes.
- So, you know about Jewish delis...
but you don't know about
the Jewish afterlife?
- I'm thinking I may
name my son after you.
- How could you name your son after me?
I'm not even dead yet!
- This is so good!
- Should I get you an Uber?
- Are you still seeing that shiksa?
- What?
- The Gentile girl.
- We broke up.
- Oh, that's good.
- Hey mom.
Hey mom.
- Hi, how are you?
- Mom, Uncle Seymour says hi.
No, no, I'm not hurt, I'm just on a date.
- Yes, he's lost weight.
- You should tell her I'm Jewish.
- I'm not gonna tell her you're...
(chatter on phone)
Yes, she's Jewish.
- I've gained weight.
Yeah.
- Love you, too.
- Hey mom.
- All right, mom, okay, I gotta get off.
Okay, all right.
All right.
- So, you're more like Jew-ISH.
- Really just Jew-ISH.
- Just Jew--
- Jew-ISH.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- Happy Hanukkah!
- Yeah, man, make a wish!
And what a Hanukkah it's been.